en fait elle a une maladie qui s'appelle
une neuropathie à petite chipie une
maladie assez grave et qui est sous
jacent de malades y ait encore plus
graves telles que des maladies auto
immunes des cancers c'est quoi en fait
en fait la quantité d'eau alors elle a
des brûlures dans tout le corps il ya
comme des décharges électriques qui
provoque des spasmes il ya le rythme
cardiaque qui s'accélère ça peut aussi
engendrer des problèmes de déglutition
des gros problèmes respiratoires c'est
un vrai calvaire en fait pour pour les
gens qui ont ce syndrome parce que les
douleurs sont énormes et les traitements
sont difficiles à enfin voilà à doser
adaptés à la pathologie ça peut ça peut
ça ça joue sur sa carrière parce qu on a
vu qu'elles avaient elles avaient annulé
des concerts
qu'elle a un traitement ça peut ça peut
se guérir ou pas alors ça dépend en fait
de ce que face au vent la neuropathie à
petit ivre et ce comme je vous le disais
est sous jacente d'une maladie beaucoup
plus grave donc tout dépend ce que je
peux pas vous dire le traitement qu'elle
a puisque ça dépend vraiment de la
maladie qu'elle a en dessous mais c'est
en fait ça révèle quand même un état un
état assez grave et les douleurs que ça
engendre
parce que ça peut aller jusqu'en même
jusqu'à la paralysie d'ailleurs on l'a
d'elle à elle à communiquer là-dessus et
c'est très très grave et elle a
contracté cette maladie il ya un an
voilà mathieu assez notamment une main
et des muses des muscles qui fait que
peut-être à internet pourra plus se
tenir debout donc la f1 qu'il est
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de repos on
parle de deux ans ce qui est important
c'est qu'elle a annulée toute sa tournée
américaine le loewe sable coatch tourc'h
entièrement annulé quand même pas
déplacé elle annulé vegas était une
résidence de 1 an et demi lady gaga déjà
eu cette maladie elle a dû se reposer
deux ans et battles et d'égal fait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup moins tourné
ou l'ars et des concerts un peu plus
court à mieux les distances oui mais
c'est quoi c'est dû à quoi en fait
d'alors notamment fait que ce qu'on a
dit c'est que quand on avait gaz pour
ceux qui sont pas allés il y avait une
idée géniale c'est que là la scène est
tout le temps un petit peu comme ça tant
que vous soyez devant ou derrière vous
voyez tout le temps mais du coup
l'artiste lui il est tout le temps un
petit peu penché et tirent sur tous ses
muscles de l'ariège et elle a tellement
fait de beggas qu'aujourd'hui ça a tiré
sur ses muscles et 7 fibromyalgie c'est
ce qui fait que ses muscles en train de
se détériorer sclérosé tu parles de
céline dion de lévis gagne à la sueur de
ses missions est-ce que céline dion elle
a quand même contracté cette maladie
afin là ça depuis un an et bon après
voilà le lien n'a pas été fait avec le
vaccin mais c'est aussi lunaires des
syndromes la
non mais je dis pas que le lien a été
fait mais c'est aussi l'une des lunes
des l'une des conséquences de ça alors
là vous avancez un peu je ne dis pas que
la presse a lâché miser pour toute la
presse canadienne et américaine il
n'évoque pas ce lien que vous évoquez
vous alors en revanche et c'est une
maladie qui est difficile à
diagnostiquer donc on l'a laissé
s'installer et c'est vrai que il ya les
troupes de l' équilibre dont parlait
mathieu pour le moment les concerts à
paris en septembre sont pas annulés il
ya six dates complètes il ya les
vieilles charrues en 2023 qui ne sont
pas annulées tout est plein et
normalement elles recommencent à
birmingham en angleterre en mai mais
pour le moment
j'ai un peu la pente en tout de la
tournée européenne n'est pas du lait
corduant mais effectivement et ce sera
un mois de juillet en france mais c'est
quand même assez mal parti il faut
qu'elle se repose deux ans aux états
unis on entraîne quelque chose qui vous
très chers ils sont en train de refaire
une scène entièrement à plate non qu'il
soit pour elle pour qu'elle se déplace
un petit peu moins et puis à la 56 a
exigé aussi malgré tout la voix des
jeunes 56 ème rang 7e
avec 15 octobre - et c'est normal quand
elle chante parce que ouais pas lars
eller mais les avocats chuchotent avec
un acte avant moi
et cette maladie femmes c'est aussi que
du coup son état allait enfin elle est
vraiment très dépréciée qu'elle l'était
déjà depuis la mort de rené est
évidemment cet état fait que bell va
elle va très mal elle est très très
maigre et
c'est très difficile pour elle en ce
moment